je vous propose maintenant de voir ce
qui se passe sur le front l'armée russe
est elle en train de gagner du terrain
dans l'est l'ukraine reprendrait le
contrôle de certaines villes avant d'en
débattre on fait le point avec famille
et ricker
la reddition des soldats de la syrie à
l'ostal signes définitifs de la chute de
la ville portuaire de marioupol sur les
bords de la mer d'azov mais les russes
mettent la main sur un champ de ruines
pour cet expert il s'agit d'une victoire
en trompe l'oeil au bout de trois mois
on peut dire que la russie n'a pas
atteint ses objectifs stratégiques
qu'elles se contentent de
d'objectifs opérationnels
c'est à dire d'avoir conquis le pourtour
de la mer d'azov et de conquérir une
partie du donbass une région où les
défense ukrainienne résiste pourtant
avec succès tout en menant des contre
attaques au nord de kharkiv et tandis
que l'armée russe subi de lourdes pertes
et des problèmes de réapprovisionnement
du côté ukrainien les livraisons d'armes
européennes commencent à produire leurs
effets dès lors la ligne de front
pourrait se figer on va s'installer
probablement dans une guerre de position
un petit peu du type 14-18 si j'ose dire
où l'artillerie aura un rôle important
et les positions défensives préparer
auront un rôle important également mardi
le ministre de la guerre ukrainien
indiqué que le conflit avec moscou entré
dans une phase prolongée selon le
dernier décompte des nations unies le
conflit aurait déjà causé la mort de
plus de 7800 civile sur le territoire
ukrainien
beaucoup d'informations beaucoup d'image
a analysé a commenté dans ce débat avec
mes invités galia ackerman bonsoir vous
retrouvez vous êtes historienne
spécialiste de la russie post-soviétique
irina dmitri shikin bonsoir maître de
conférences à l'inalco responsable des
études du craignent n j'accueille
également christian lequesne bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
professeur à sciences po paris matthieu
croissandeau est resté à mes côtés
évidemment
84e jour de cette guerre en ukraine
galia ackerman alors il ya marioupol
évidemment ça fait un peu partie des
images du du jour mais est ce que comme
on le disait dans le reportage pour vous
c'est plus symbolique que
stratégiquement important la chute
définitive de marioupol il y avait cette
poche de résistance qui était en train
de tomber c'est vrai je pense que en
soit cette poche de résistance n'avaient
pas beaucoup d'impact parce que les
russes contrôlées la ville de mario paul
et qu'il y ait ou non ses poches de
résistance ça demandait simplement des
efforts supplémentaires pour entourer
complètement cirque les usines et
empêcher toute sortie de cette usine
c'est ce qui finalement a fait donc
là la reddition à terme des militaires
ukrainien inévitable tout simplement
parce que le tunnel qu'ils utilisaient
pour s'approvisionner en eau et ça c'est
encore plus important que la nourriture
de la rivière
ce tunnel a été bombardé il est devenu
inaccessible et donc
symboliquement
ce combat était quelque chose
d'absolument incroyable
tout aussi incroyable qu'en 2015 la
bataille pour l'aéroport de donetsk qui
a duré un an et l'appareil pareil le
bâtiment était en ruines les rapports
étaient totalement en ruine c'était
juste un symbole
donc sur le champ de bataille sur le
port la guerre ça ne joue pas de rôle
très important et pas très important
irina dmitri chine est ce qu'on sait si
l'armée ukrainienne progresse reprend
des villes perdues on en a entendu le
président
zelensky la firme et bien d'un du côté
de râles qu'il d'abord le fait que rare
qu'yves soir des enclaves et que donc
les apparemment les forces russes
pour l'instant renonce à prendre la
ville et ensuite il n'y a peut-être pas
de grandes villes qui était libéré mais
des petits villages des bourgades
ensuite le fait qu'on ait empêché les
russes de traverser donne est donc ça
aussi ça a rendu impossible alors leur
avance et donc donc cdd petite victoire
symbolique est importante quand même
christian lequesne il ya dans le
reportage entendez ce terme de guerre de
position est ce que vous êtes d'accord
est ce que c'est un peu ce qui est en
train de se dessiner oui on a le
sentiment effectivement que ça ressemble
un peu
la première mondiale ce qui est d'un
archaïsme quand même assez
extraordinaire
ça va se figer pour l'en des positions
figées des tirs de canon et des tirs
d'artillerie
donc on n'entrevoit pas de solution de
paix c'est ça qui me paraît être
le point le point à souligner on a
l'impression d'une sorte d'embourbement
dont on ne connaît pas la fin
dans ce rapport de forces est évidemment
là la puissance des armes
dans un communiqué l'elysée a confirmé
je cite que les livraisons d'armes par
la france pour suivre on est gagnant en
intensité dans les jours et les semaines
qui viennent de même que l'acheminement
d'équipement humanitaire
irina dmitri chine et est ce qu'on sait
qu'ils payent pour ces armes ça fait
plusieurs jours que je me pose la
question et l'ukraine qui sera en pleine
reconstruction l'espère le plus
rapidement possible at elle les moyens
de payer cet armement et seconde à la
réponse à cette question lorsqu'il ya
des
schémas un peu un peu complexe donc il
ya une partie qui est payée directement
par le cren une partie est financée par
les états qui donc annonce la livraison
de ces armes et donc qui ne paie pas à
l'ukraine mais plutôt mettre cet argent
à l'achat ou au financement de ces armes
soient dans leur propre pays soit dans
les pays tiers dont l'ancien bloc de
l'est qui disposait de ses armements ex
soviétiques qui n'étaient pas utilisés
mais qui serait
utile aux yeux aux ukrainiens dans la
mesure où il maîtrise ses armements en
même temps on est quand même très
content d'avoir les les armements
modernes qui vient de
d'europe de france de grande bretagne ou
des états unis parce que ce sont ces
armes là qui à terme vont quand même
renversé le rapport de force puisque
l'armée russe étant privée de
technologie occidentale etc on a
notamment parlé je ne sais pas dans
quelle mesure c'est anecdotique on
trouvait des puces normalement utilisé
pour les réfrigérateurs qui sont
maintenant on mise sur les sur les
fusées donc donc ça montre à quel point
on est à court de cette électronique
deux de ses armements ensuite viendra la
réparation de tout le matériel qui avait
été endommagé et l'a de nouveau
l'ukraine va dépasser les forces russes
et donc peut-être ça qui rendirent sera
quand même là la situation sur le front
galia ackerman est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on
peut évaluer la quantité impressionnante
d'armes qui ont été fournies par les
occidentaux à l'ukraine depuis le début
de la guerre depuis presque depuis trois
mois maintenant parce que il ya il ya
une part de de flou alors on peut
comprendre que on ne donne pas tous les
détails des armes qui sont livrés voilà
mes mais certains pays sont plus
transparent que notre là dessus oui on a
des pots pour certains pays on sait que
l'allemagne libre étant de chars que la
france un livre est peut-être temps d'un
d'installation de ceci ou de cela
notamment des canons qui s'appelle césar
voilà on a parlé mais je pense que
grosso modo
marty du secret militaire est donc tout
à fait de façon délibérée aux nomes des
chiffres plutôt dead en dollar ou en
euro et on sait que les états unis je
pense malgré la résistance d'un
sénateurs vont vont adopter donc ce
décret qui a déjà été signée par le
président biden sur le lien important
sur 39,8 milliards de dollars et donc on
peut imaginer que il s'agit quand même
de quantité tout à fait
conséquente et même très conséquente et
je voudrais ajouter à ce que irina vient
de dire j'ai lu ce matin que par exemple
lysine de renom à moscou qui s'appelle
avtovaz elle a été cédée par renom à ses
partenaires russes parce que maintenant
il ya quand même beaucoup d'entreprises
françaises qui ont quitté la russie à la
suite de cette guerre est bien les
ouvriers se trouve presque tout le temps
en arrêt forcé parce qu'il n'y a plus de
pièces détachées et ça va être pareil
bien sûr pour l'armée
bruce ce qui fait que même certains
militaires russes maintenant
commence à
voir pour dire que cette guerre même la
russie droit dans le mur ça veut dire
que d'un côté il ya les états unis les
pays occidentaux qui qui fournissent un
flux régulier d'armes à l'ukraine et de
l'autre vous êtes en train de nous dire
que il ya un flux keynes qui n'existe
pas ou qui se tarit
bah écoute et ils ont annoncé par
exemple hier qu'une grande usine
militaire qui s'appelle oural match a
donc fabriqué une colonne de chars qui
vont être livrés au front mais donc ils
sont obligés comme pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale maintenant commencer à
produire des armements dont ils ont une
pénurie quand même les experts
britanniques mal hulk entière de leurs
équipements ont déjà été utilisés en
ukraine et dans les conditions où ils
n'ont pas de pièces détachées ou n'ont
pas de pièces d'électronique ça risque
très vite de tournai comme on dit au
vinaigre il ya une information de la
journée c'est cette déclaration de la
présidente de la commission européenne
ursula von der leyen elle annonce aussi
aujourd'hui à une nouvelle assistance je
cite une nouvelle assistance macro
financière exceptionnelle de 9 milliards
d'euros en 2022 je suis pas sûr de bien
comprendre une nouvelle science macro
financière exceptionnelle s'est
volontairement floues christian lequesne
sescousse et non dissociation alors paye
pour ces armes en attendant un
remboursement de l'ukraine je reste un
peu sur cette question de que se
distingue de la question de l'aide
militaire les militaires
existent aussi au niveau de l'union
européenne et d'ailleurs c'est inédit
puisque c'est là c'est la première fois
que l'union européenne finance des armes
sur son budget propre sur une sur un
programme qu'on appelle les facilités de
la paye qui vient d'être augmentée
d'ailleurs pile on avait déjà donné un
milliard cinq cent mille on est passé à
2 milliards mais ensuite il ya le
soutien si vous voulez à la
macroéconomie ukrainienne
ça veut dire le soutien à l'économie
dans ces grands indicateurs
vous imaginez bien qu'il faut quand même
du cash pour pouvoir faire des
importations alimentaires pour pouvoir
payer les salaires des fonctionnaires
fondamentaux de l'économie ukrainienne
voilà 6 et 9 milliards qui ont été
annoncées aujourd'hui par madame von der
leyen
concerne cette partie là de l'aide
d'accord irina et on parle aussi de mint
condition des réformes c'est à dire que
cet argent doit aussi d' aller de pair
avec la modernisation du système du
monde d'autant plus qu'il ya une demande
d'adhésion de l'ukraine allait
évidemment mais ça veut dire qu'avec ses
flux qu'on a décrit c'est à dire tout
cet argent ailleurs d'ukraine toutes ses
armes karim en ukraine et l inverse la
russie de plus en plus isolé et qui a du
mal à reproduire est ce qu'on se saisir
que l'ukraine a déjà gagné la guerre
enfin non je ne crois pas que le cren a
gagné la guerre mais la perspective
qu'elle gagne est assez assez probable
tout simplement parce que et il y aura
un moment où poutine sera devant le
choix et ce qu'il fait une mobilisation
générale où il arrête les hostilités et
s'il fait même la mobilisation générale
qui va provoquer beaucoup de remous dans
la société russe est-ce que c'est
militaire
nouvellement donc appelé sous les
drapeaux est ce qu'il aura assez
d'armement pour pour les équiper alors
que l'ukraine a un potentiel d'un
million d'hommes qui est qu'elle peut
mettre sous les drapeaux et si elle le
flux ininterrompu je pense que rien que
les 40 milliards américains ça signifie
beaucoup d'armement donc à terme il
pleut il pleut il peut arriver une
situation où l'armée ukrainienne sera
même un nombre supérieur à l'armée russe
et là vous savez il ya deux solutions
soit la russie pratiquement se retire
même sens prononcé en fin formellement
de capitulation mais bon ils peuvent
toujours trouver des raisons oui puisque
officiellement ils ne sont pas en guerre
exactement
d'avoir rempli conditions on peut
toujours transformer une défaite en une
victoire factice
mais soit et ils seront obligés de se
retirer soit il restera donc la dernière
arme qui est l'armé nucléaire on peut
pas totalement rayés cette menace mais
là aussi il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent que si les affaires vont aller
vraiment mal comme poutine se trouve
dans sa bulle dans une construction
totalement fausses
du monde
il peut y avoir quand même au moins une
tentative d'un coup d'état
parce que parce que tout le bateau
probablement sombré avec un dernier mot
sur ce thème qui sur le caine ensuite on
parle de de ce jeune soldat qui est
jugée à kiev où il à la question des
composants électroniques est absolument
fondamental aujourd'hui pour mener une
guerre c'est à dire qu'une guerre
aujourd'hui
c'est aussi une guerre que l'on mène
avec l'électronique la logistique la
nuit notamment l'électronique exactement
et nous avons vu dans des dans des
guerres précédentes
que le manque que pouvait être cruel je
pense en particulier à l'intervention
britannique et française en libye si
nous n'avions pas eu la logistique
américaine
nous aurions eu du mal à à progresser
dans dans l'opération et là on avait
déjà une situation de pénurie des
composants électroniques avant la guerre
avant la guerre mais vous pouvez
imaginer que aujourd'hui avec les
sanctions les japonais par exemple ne
livre rien je peux imaginer que les
taïwanais font font pareil donc
effectivement les russes vont se
retrouver avec un gros gros problème
technologique qui est un des avantages
énormes dans cette bière très
intéressant vous l'avez évoqué la
jeunesse des soldats russes c'est l'une
des images du
jour ce solde a jugé pour crimes de
guerre son procès s'est ouvert à kif un
soldat de 21 ans accusé d'avoir abattu
et un civils non armés écoutez il a
plaidé coupable
est ce que vous comprenez ce dont vous
êtes accusé
oui
plaidez vous coupable
complètement vous ne refusez pas de
témoigner non
irina dmitri chine c'est ce qu'on peut
dire que la justice ukrainienne réagi
rapidement c'est assez rare de
d'assister à un procès comme celui-là
pour crimes de guerre alors que le
conflit n'est pas terminé oui mais je
pense que c'est très important
aujourd'hui c'est un premier procès il y
en aura d'autres et c'est la justice
ukrainienne est allé si vite c'est parce
qu'elle était déjà en contact avec
notamment le tribunal pénal
international puisqu'il ya le procès de
brignac rennes en 14 donc il ya tous
ceux tous ses contacts qui ont été noués
et ce qui a permis aux autorités
ukrainiennes de très rapidement mettre
en place le travail d'abord de
constatations mais c'est un procès il
faut qu'il y ait surtout il ya quand
même la question sous jacente des crimes
contre l'humanité voire de génocide donc
je pense qu'on a commencé par un procès
où les choses sont claires où les choses
sont simples où on a absolument pu
établir de manière limpide ce qui s'est
passé en plus on a le coupable ça
prendra plus de temps
à faire d'autres d'autres passés ou mais
c'est de la communication a dessiné sur
des soldats russes je pense qu'il ya une
partie de communication puisque ça
montre aux soldats russes et aux
responsables russes surtout que personne
n'échappera à sa responsabilité et que
dans peut-être que si ça permet ensuite
donc qu'ils aient une attitude plus
clémente à l'égard des civils ou qu'ils
refusent d ordres criminels ça peut bien
sûr avoir avoir même là l'impact
pratique aujourd'hui et je pense c'est
dimension éthique est extrêmement
importante et puis c'est aussi une
démonstration de fonctionnement de la de
la justice là aussi on peut considérer
ma tu as raison qu'on est dans une forme
de communication serge l'ukraine
montrent il a un avocat ce jeune soldat
enfin j'imagine galia ackerman que tout
ça se fait dans le respect des droits de
l'ukrainien wii était aussi du droit
international comment on peut l'analyser
certainement savait d'emblée par exemple
après les massacres abuja mais aussi
dans d'autres localités il y avait même
des gendarmes français qui ont été
dépêchés il y avait toutes sortes de
commissions internationales qui ont été
créés qui ont enquêté sur place et ses
trains et aujourd'hui à la différence
des guerres du passé il ya beaucoup de
crimes qui ont été documentés en direct
rien qu'avec les smartphones donc par
exemple pour ce soldat on sait qu'il a
tiré sur un un homme à vélo de 62 ans
il paraît que c'était l'ordre de son
supérieur
on sait pas si c'était un ordre direct
aussi le supérieur à 10 ben tu tire sur
tout ce qui bouge par exemple donc ça ça
on va établir au cours du procès mais
c'est un crime qui a été documentée et
ce qui est
paradoxal c'est que le lendemain ce
petit soldat de 21 ans il s'est rendu
ensemble avec son supérieur qui
paraît-il aurait mis donc cet ordre de
tirer encore deux autres soldats bien
sûr c'est d'autant plus important pour
le cren à part l'effet médiatique et cet
instant que
la république populaire de donetsk on
veut organiser aussi des procès et
prépare un tribunal pour les soldats et
notamment ceux qui se sont rendus qui
appartenaient au régiment aof pour les
accusés de crimes de guerre parce que
beaucoup parmi eux ont combattu dans le
dôme basse en 2014 2015
on est bien d'accord les séparatistes
pro russes qui vont juger des ukrainiens
oui absolument et donc il y aura aussi
une sorte de bataille de différentes
justice bien que la justice de cette
république autoproclamée
c'est peut-être une justice entre
guillemets je voudrais qu'on revoie les
l'image de ce jeune soldat je vais vous
livrer ma réaction quand cet après midi
j'ai j'ai vu ces images voilà ce que je
me suis dit c'est le premier visage de
la barbarie de l'armée russe il a une
gueule d'ange à peine sortis de
l'adolescence
christian lequesne est ce que enfin moi
c'est ce qui m'a frappé alors c'est quoi
c'est révélateur de vous l'avez évoqué
de la jeunesse des soldats russes il dit
chez les battent pour pouvoir soutenir
financièrement ma ma grand mère je suis
en train de chercher des excuses mais
mais quand même cette image aller
frappante
ben vous savez les régimes autoritaires
mais les démocraties aussi ont toujours
mobilisé la jeunesse vous vous rappelez
des images de ces jeunes soldats
allemands de 16 17 ans notamment à la
fin de la guerre quand salée quand ça
allait mal en
1944 on avait vraiment l'impression de
gamins qu'on envoyait
qu'on envoyait offrant qu'on envoyait à
la boucherie bon bah c'est un peu c'est
un peu là c'est un peu la même chose je
crois que cette cette armée russe
il va falloir avec le recul qu'on qu'on
la connaisse aussi un peu mieux qu'on
travaille un peu sur sa sociologie
ce qu'on nous dit c'est que c'est une
armée où vous avez d'un côté ces soldats
qui sont souvent très jeunes de l'autre
vous avez les officiers les officiers
supérieurs mais vous avez un manque de
corps intermédiaires c'est à dire en
gros vous n'avez pas de sous-officiers
et vous n'avez vous avez très peu de
d'officiers subalternes et
d'encadrement n'a pas d'encadrement et
peut-être ceci explique-t-il aussi
pourquoi cette armée peut se livrer
aussi facilement des exactions mais
j'aimerais immédiatement a ajouté que
toutes les armes et se livrent à des
exactions vous savez dans des dans les
périodes de guerre hélas c'est bien le
côté terribles de la guerre il ya kerman
vous savez il ya quand même quelque
chose qu'il faut aussi prendre en compte
la société russe est une société
extrêmement violente il ya beaucoup de
violence domestique
il ya beaucoup de violence dans les
relations entre les patrons et les
subalternes et l'armée est un lieu de
violence par excellence ça a été comme
ça à l'époque soviétique
et c'est devenu encore pire à l'époque
post soviétique il ya systématiquement
le bizutage des jeunes par les aînés si
l'on peut dire et
il ya eu des cas par exemple est un pas
longtemps un jeune tatar a tout
simplement ouvert le feu dans sa caserne
et l'a tué plusieurs personnes nous
simplement parce qu'ils n'en pouvaient
plus de ce bizutage donc là on entend
dire ça je pense aux tueries de masse
aux états unis qui explique ce que je
veux dire
c'est pas la russie n'est pas le seul
pays gangrené par la violence non bien
sûr c'est pas le seul mais je ne sais
pas si par exemple dans l'armée
américaine
la violence
d'institutionnaliser alors qu'ici il
s'agit pratiquement d'une violence
institutionnalisée c'est à dire la
première année on montre aux jeunes
soldats qu'il est rien rien du tout et
moins que rien et qu'il doit obéir au
beer non seulement un souvenir archives
mais aussi à ses camarades qui peuvent
lui demander toutes sortes de tâches
humiliante le passé à tabac et ses
trains et donc cette violence est
ensuite reproduites et je pense que je
ne suis pas sûr qu'on ait donné des
ordres directs par exemple le soldat aux
militaires russes de violer les femmes
et parfois les enfants les jeunes
enfants ukrainiens de foot masculin et
féminin
c'est totalement agréable mais je pense
que il suffit simplement qu' on ne les
empêche pas pour que cette violence
déborde quelque part je voudrais qu'on
consacre du temps également à l'autre
fait majeur de cette journée c'est une
confirmation la finlande et la suède ont
soumis officiellement leur demande
d'adhésion à l'otan l'organisation du
traité de l'atlantique nord qui regroupe
aujourd'hui 30 états on va voir cette
carte des pays membres de
l'otan est ce que christian lequesne
vous dirais que cette demande d'adhésion
alors ça coince un peu parce que la
turquie membre de l'otan voilà
n'y est pas favorable mais bon peut-être
pas entrer dans ces détails là mais
plutôt sur ce que ça dit de la stratégie
de lanières poutine s'est quand même
constat d'échec en creux pour pour le
président russe bien sûr puisque cette
question de l'adhésion bon elle se pose
en finlande depuis quelque temps c'est à
dire qu'il ya un débat qui est bien
antérieure à la guerre en ukraine mais
en même temps ce débat n'était pas
n'était pas actif au point de devenir
réelle aussi vite et donc c'est
évidemment la guerre en ukraine qui là
qu'il a réactivé en suède c'est encore
plus extraordinaire parce que je
souhaite c'est une c'est une neutralité
historiques qui datent de
fin depuis des siècles en finlande
c'était une neutralité plutôt imposé par
la fin de la seconde guerre mondiale est
là et la guerre froide et tout ça est
passé
au parlement d'une façon rapide
qui eût cru qu il ne faudrait pas d'un
référendum par exemple dans un pays
comme la suède qui est quand même
habitués à utiliser le référendum et ben
voilà on y est on y est et effectivement
je pense que monsieur poutine on peut
s'en prendre qu'à lui même
il a il a tout fait pour que pour que
cette situation arrive vous parliez de
référendum et de l'opinion on a on a les
résultats d'un sondage récent je pense
qu'on peut retrouver cette infographie
sur justement les réactions de la
population de ces deux pays sur le
soutien
sur l'adhésion à l'otan on à 64% des
finlandais qui se disent pour
effectivement en suède c'est ce qu'ont
piper on est à 51 % des suédois irina
dmitri shikin comment vous analysez ces
chiffres est ce que une partie des
suédois craint encore la réaction de la
lumière poutine mais ce que je veux dire
je pense qu'il est d'abord il suffit de
voir la carte c'est comme la finlande
qui est en première ligne 2010 300 km de
frontière commune mais en même temps je
tiens toujours à ce qu'on montre
l'ensemble de la carte et là on verra
l'immense russie il a toute petite
finlande dont honnêtement c'est c'est
vraiment disproportionnée parce que
quand on aussi on focalise effectivement
sur les 1000 km mais quand on ramène les
choses à leur vraie proportion n'est pas
du tout dans cette image là les finnois
quand même mon vécu dans cette grande
depuis des années et des années et des
années et c'est bien évidemment les
situations en ukraine qui a accéléré les
choses et donc ils ont je pense
parfaitement raison d'avoir sauté le pas
la suède leur emboîtent le pas peut-être
pour des raisons historiques parce que
ce n'est pas la suède qui a livré la
guerre à la russie soviétique ou à
l'union soviétique
donc avoir la seconde guerre mondiale ce
n'est pas la suède qui s'est vue amputée
d'une partie des territoires ce qui
était le cas de la finlande donc donc il
ya aussi une raison historique pour
l'épauler finnois d'avoir d'avoir peur
et est bon la suite je pense à se
retrouver entre entre entre deux pays
il a fait ce choix qui je suis d'accord
avec vous pour des raisons historiques
paraît vraiment exceptionnel mais la
réalité s'impose à cette situation c'est
pas la seule situation d'hier
diplomatique installée depuis des années
voire des décennies qui est bousculé par
ce conflit en ukraine d'autres chiffres
qu'on peut vous donner le sur le l'armée
à la fois de la finlande et de la suède
l'armée finlandaise ses 280 mille
soldats apte au combat et 600000
réservistes l'armée suédoise s'est
beaucoup plus modeste cinquante mille
soldats avec un retour du service
militaire obligatoire qui a été décidé
ensuite c'était en 2017 galia ackerman
c'est que c'est une lapalissade mais il
faut peut-être l'analyse le rappeler il
analysé que viennent chercher ces deux
pays-là la protection tout simplement
des états unis derrière derrière l'otan
certainement la protection je pense à
cette série qui est peut-être n'a pas eu
un succès énorme mais il ya eu une série
norvégienne qui s'appelait occupants qui
était une sorte d'utopie ou de dystopie
qui donc
développer le scénario d'une occupation
militaire
de la norvège par la russie à cause des
hydrocarbures donc c'est quelque chose
quand vous lisez même la littérature des
pays scandinaves
c'est peu de la russie est très souvent
présentes on a
on a peur de ce grand voisin qui
d'ailleurs fait souvent des expos des
incursions dans le ciel de ces pays et
donc c'est cette peur qui maintenant
c'est à augmenter
depuis
l'invasion de l'ukraine et j'ajoute
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai j'ai lu que les
suisses commencent à penser à l'adhésion
à l'otan si cela se réalise
ce serait vraiment un choc le point le
point le point important dans l'adhésion
à l'otan c'est la clause de solidarité
en cas d'attaqué bien sûr c'est le
fameux article 5 du traité de
l'atlantique nord
si vous êtes attaqués l'ensemble des
autres états membres de l'otan doivent
être solidaires dans la défense et oui
et d'ailleurs ça ça change tout parce
que c'est l'ukraine seraient membres de
l'otan il y aurait des soldats de l'otan
qui combattrait si j'ai bien compris ce
que vous dites on peut pas refaire
l'histoire mais effectivement si on
avait donné suite au sommet de bucarest
en 2008 avec ce qu'on avait appelé à
l'époque le processus map
peut-être que l'otan peut-être que
l'ukraine serait entrée dans l'otan et
qu'on n'aurait pas eu aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la guerre mais ça sert faire
l'histoire je j'ajoute quand même que ce
sont surtout les français les allemands
qui s'y sont opposés à l'époque parce
qu'il ne fallait pas provoquer monsieur
poutine alors justement la réaction du
président russe à cette annonce
officielle de demande d'adhésion de la
suède et de la finlande à l'otan on
écoute le président russe
finlande suède je voudrais vous informer
chers collègues que la russie n'a aucun
problème avec ces états un tel
élargissement de l'otan à ces pays ne
constitue pas une menace immédiate pour
nous pour la russie mais le déploiement
d'infrastructures militaires sur les
territoires de ces pays entraînera bien
sûr une réponse
gaillac et comment il faut comprendre
cette réaction de manière continue on
peut on peut dire vraiment de
deux sentiments ou deux messages qui
cherche à faire passer assez opposé un
message d'apaisement et en même temps
une menace oui c'est vrai mais il a
assez raison quand il dit qu'il n'a pas
de problème particulier avec la finlande
et la suède surtout quand ces pays
étaient neutres mais ça montre en même
temps que le prétexte de du désir de
l'ukraine d'adhérer à l'otan n'était
qu'un prétexte le vrai problème de
poutine son obsession de longue date
c'est le cren qu'elle soit a le temps ou
qu'il ne soit pas le temps je tels soins
dans l'union européenne qu'elle ne soit
pas dans l'union européenne
poutine considère que ce pays ne doit
pas exister il faut comprendre ça une
fois pour toutes il ne veut pas que la
nation ukrainienne existe et que ce pays
existe et le voeu que la place est liée
à un patchwork de petits états neutres
et contrôlé par la russie on l'a déjà
dit ici mais parce qu'il considère que
c'est le le berceau de la russie
éternelle en quelque sorte
ils le disent mais je crois que la vraie
raison c'est même pas cela la vraie
raison profonde c'est que d'une part il
veut reconstruire l'empiré russe et vous
voyez que aujourd'hui on peut parler ce
que ce que j'ai écrit déjà ya trois ans
soviétisme son communisme retour au
soviétisme sans communisme fondé des
communistes quand vous voyez aujourd'hui
les soldats russes installés partout il
arriva donc à gagner le tri du
territoire
le drapeau rouge qu'il qu'ils appellent
aujourd'hui le drapeau toujours fait
avec fois-ci marteau mais qu'ils disent
aujourd'hui le drapeau de la victoire
parce que c'était la victoire dans la
seconde guerre mondiale et qu'il
installe des statues de lénine dans des
villages ukrainien c'est certainement
pas un retour à l'idéologie communiste
ou quoi que ce soit c'est le pur
soviétisme c'est le ce sont des symboles
de l'union soviétique qui sont en train
de réinstaller et est donc
ce que je veux dire c'est que poutine
veut reconstruire l'union soviétique il
a plus ou mois annoncé peut-être pas
dans la forme total qu'il a eu avant
l'éclatement mais sans l'ukraine il peut
pas le faire l'ukraine est nécessaire à
cette construction
impérialistes rester avec nous comme
chaque semaine public sénat vous propose
maintenant un flash d'infos à
destination des réfugiés ukrainien de
france quand un calme et va pouvoir nous
nous rejoindre et irina vous allez
traduire les informations que nous vous
donnons le tout premier rebond soir
quentin le tout premier procès d'un
soldat russe pour crimes de guerre s'est
donc ouvert aujourd'hui à kiev à payer
la dîme et chichi marine à 21 ans il est
accusé d'avoir abattu un civil de 62 ans
le 28 février dernier dans le nord-est
l'ukraine il a plaidé coupable accusé de
crimes de guerre et meurtre avec
préméditation
le militaire originaire de sibérie
encourt la prison à perpétuité
votre chemin
nous sommes au 84e jour de l'invasion
russe en ukraine le ministère russe de
la défense a annoncé aujourd'hui que
près de 1000 militaires ukrainien
retranchés dans l'usiné asos talent de
marioupol se sont rendus ce sont les
autorités russes qui ont publié les
images que vous ayez sur votre écran
mais sinon ça tu te rhdp d'agneau cisco
offre de magna vous croyez non mr benard
s'ils veulent nous
avons
adressé aux pauvres nabagné aussi ce
convoi d'un festival de cinéma de cannes
s'est ouvert hier par un acte fort elle
avec l'apparition surprise par écran
interposé du président ukrainien devant
un artère de stars nous allons continuer
à nous battre a dit volodymyr zelensky
marquant son discours de petites
références au cinéma qu'en ski festival
et graisses saturées spotters stores inc
zadi qui pour moi est présidente hawk
eye in christ vers nous car nos deux
héros d ibra lycée qui désirent qui
n'est pas toujours été mon amoureux du
beau cadavre d'amazon ce qui paraissait
pas je serai promo de foot hamas qui
n'étaient pas
in children
chaignat yvonne est née aujourd'hui cela
braselton signate
à réussir mutuellement procès à charge
qui n'ont monstre a beau but de romaric
ya chez eux un diktat ya juillet vie
nasa ce beau monde est une chose non via
qui te dit c'est nasri y met ce titre
chuzzle chine c'est qu'ils n'ont pas et
il y existe et on termine par une
information pratique pour les ukrainiens
réfugié à paris ou en ile de france la
ville de paris et l'ambassade d'ukraine
en france invite toutes les familles
déplacées à une réunion dite amical
rendez vous samedi 21 mai de 14h30 à 18h
17 rue de verneuil dans le 7e
arrondissement l'occasion de se
renseigner sur toutes sortes de
démarches administratives comme
l'inscription des enfants à l'école
petric nos informations les six mêmes
prémisses aussi bluegreen japonais c'est
au paris sg ou paris ce congrès yoni ile
de france
médiapart et j'aspire l'espace austin
green au fresne s'est rapproché du green
screen
libre n y avait deux bouts de 7,27 par
chautagne internaxx de traits titre
provisionnel 7 euros des adresses vous
de savoir n'a ici menace ou sont opposés
par et jean spain in abu dhabi de deux
epr aussi admis streep amy partie des
désagréments causés post it et de
secours
merci lina merci content pour pour ce
flash destinées aux réfugiés
l'ukrainien en france irina dmitri chine
est ce que ça vous surprend qu'on fasse
qu'on propose ça sur public sénat parce
que c'est que c'est quand même
particulier de s'adresser en ukrainien
et à quoi il ya cinquante mille
ukrainien à peu près en france
aujourd'hui c'est ça j'ai trouvé ça je
pense que 70 alors moi j'avais le site
de 75000 qui était passé mais que je
vous fais beaucoup plus confiance que
quelqu'un car mes premières sotheby's en
soixante dix mille je pense que les
chiffres bouger donc il y aura sans
doute d'autres personnes qui vont venir
ceci étant aujourd'hui depuis le 9 mai
le nombre de retours dépasse le nombre
de départs en ukraine il ya peut-être
aussi des choses qui vont s'inverser
pour répondre à votre question je trouve
cette initiative absolument admirable
est formidable de permettre grâce aux
services publics de parler aux
ukrainiens de faire cette émission en
bilingue donc à leurs données à la fois
ces informations en français et un
ukrainien et je trouve cette initiative
de doit être entré deux maintenus et
étendus on va le maintenir en tout cas
c'est disponibles évidemment sur le site
notre site internet
publicsenat.fr merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat